I'm worried really about how much fuzzy
thinking is going on in the world.
Know Fuzzy thinking.
Do people just not thinking straight?
Consider this following example.
Imagine you have a spelling bee.
This is contrived,
but it makes the point.
There's a spelling bee and you have to
spell the word cat.
Okay,
so one student spells it,
c,
a tea person.
Got It right.
The next person spells it,
k a t.
that's wrong.
You got that wrong.
Okay.
Third Person Spells it.
X Q,
w you realize that is marked equally is
wrong with theK ,
a t,
when you could argue that Kat is a
bitter spelling for cat.
Then C,
a t,
dictionaries know this because that's
how they spell it phonetically,
and so we've built a system for
ourselves where there is an answer and
everything else is not the answer.
Even when some answers are better than
others.
So our brains are absent the wiring
capable of coming up with an original
thought.
If you're an employer in two candidates
come up looking for a job,
and this is again a contrived example
and,
and you're interviewing the two
candidates and,
and you say,
oh,
it's part of this interview.
I just want to ask you,
what's the height of the spire on this
building that we're in?
Candidate says,
oh,
I was,
I was just,
I was a,
uh,
an architect.
I've majored in architecture for awhile
and I memorize the heights of all the
buildings on campus.
I know the height and inspire is 150
feet.
One hundred 55 feet tall.
Okay?
Turns out that's the right answer.
That's the right answer.
And a person came up with it in second.
That person goes away,
the next candidate walks in.
Do you know the height of the spire on
this building?
The candidate says,
no,
but I'll be right back.
Person runs outside measures the length
of the shadow of that spire on the
ground measures the length of his or her
own shadow ratios.
The height to the shadows comes up with
a number,
runs back inside.
It's about a 150 feet.
Who are you going to hire?
I'm hiring the person who figured it
out,
even though it took that person longer,
even though the person's answer is not
as precise.
I'm hiring that person because that
person knows how to use the mind in a
way not previously engaged.
You realize when you know how to think,
it empowers you far beyond those.
No.
Only what?
Two things.